all right today was a long time coming
we're going to cancel moonlanding
deniers those who subscribe to the
theory that the moonlanding was fake I
am finally addressing the subject on the
show because I was provoked and is very
easy to do uh baited into this
conversation over the weekend I happen
to mention on Twitter that I watched and
very much enjoyed uh for the second time
the movie first man which is um actually
we watch it with the older kids who who
really liked it as well uh the excellent
biopic about Neil Armstrong starring
Ryan Gosling
and uh and I I wasn't trying to start a
fight actually I just I like the movie
and I and I just wanted to say that but
this brought out the moonlanding deniers
perhaps predictably and I responded to
one of them saying simply that I hate
The moonlanding Conspiracy Theory
because it's not only baseless but it
also seeks to undermine the greatest
achievement in American history and that
post got hundreds of responses and much
to my sh grin though uh should not have
been to my surprise the vast majority of
the comments were from people who deny
that the moonlanding exists in fact
I basically got ratioed on Twitter for
saying that the moon landing
happened that's how bad things have
gotten now I'd like to think that my
Twitter comments are not representative
of the general public but polling says
otherwise the most recent survey I've
seen conducted in 2019 found that only
about 60% of the public strongly
disagrees with the theory that the
moonlanding was fake and that leaves
about 40% who do not strongly disagree
with the theory that the moonlanding is
fake 5% strong agree with the theory
another six or 7% agree with it less
strongly and the rest are at least to
some degree apparently open to the idea
that the moon landing never happened and
was all set up on a sound stage
somewhere in in Hollywood I guess
now the very first thing that you should
ask yourself when evaluating any
conspiracy theory it because there are
plenty of conspiracy theories that have
turned out to be true right that doesn't
mean that they're all true though so
reflexively dismissing every cons
conspiracy theory is is very low IQ but
reflexively believing all of them is
also low IQ and and so we want to be
critical thinkers and we want to um take
them on a case-by casee basis which I
think most people do so looking at a
conspiracy theory very first thing you
should ask yourself is how many people
would need to be involved for it to work
and if the answer is that a relatively
small number of highlevel powerful
people would have to be involved
then your theory at least has a chance
of passing the initial smell test but if
the answer is that the conspiracy would
necessitate the close cooperation and
secrecy of thousands of people across
multiple agencies and institutions then
you're going to have to meet a very very
high evidentiary bar to make your theory
even slightly credible the one thing we
know about human beings in general and
human beings in government especially is
that they are very bad at keeping
secrets and the chance of the secret
being kept drops exponentially as you
add more people to it we all understand
this I mean you tell one person a secret
it it's very hard to get them to keep it
tell 10 people and it's extremely
difficult to get them to keep it a
thousand is basically impossible so what
about the fake moonlanding well this
would require the coordination and
absolute secrecy of the
astronauts who are on these fake
missions and also everybody at Mission
Control it would also have to either
involve everybody at NASA or a portion
of people at Nasa and the matter is even
more incredible because that would mean
that the secret was being kept from a
bunch of people at Nasa by other people
at Nasa matter what that's a very
dubious proposition but it goes beyond
that of course knowledge of this
conspiracy would have to go up the ranks
in government not everybody in the
Pentagon and white house had to know but
some of them would would have had to
know and already we have multiple
governmental entities working together
on this and keeping the secret for
decades without a single leak but it's
not contained just the government if
this was filmed on a Sound Stage than
the film crew sound Engineers the guys
who built the props the studio or
company that owned whatever Sound Stage
they used and so on all these people
would either have to be in on it or
would have to be involved without
knowing that they're in on it which is
even less likely so now we have multiple
government agencies and dozens if not
hundreds of bureaucrats all working
together seamlessly alongside multiple
civilians some of whom work in the film
industry these are the two gossipy least
tight-lipped worlds in existence
Hollywood and government and yet after
six decades nobody in either world has
ever breathed a single word about this
ever but it's even more Fantastical than
that you may be aware that the
moonlanding occurred or was fake
supposedly in the middle of the Cold War
and that's largely why it was faked
according to the theory but the Soviets
were monitoring our space program just
as closely as we were monitoring theirs
it's inconceivable that we could have
planned set up and executed a fake moon
landing and pulled this ruse over on the
public without the Soviet it's being
fully aware of what we've done and yet
they never accused us of Faking The
Landing the Soviet Union never denied
the legitimacy of the landing one time
in fact at this point there are over 70
space agencies around the globe many of
them have their own satellites their own
probes and telescopes and so on if the
most famous space related achievement in
history was completely fake then it
would seem nearly certain that at least
some of the people and at least some of
those other Global space agencies would
know it or at least suspect it yet no
accusations have ever been made by
anybody who would be in a position to
actually know anything about this which
means either that many dozens or
hundreds of conspirators in NASA the
White House the Pentagon and Hollywood
were so brilliant and devious that they
tricked even the Soviet spies who were
monitoring them along with every other
Global space agency or these other
agencies are in on it which brings the
conspiracy to thousands of people across
dozens of countries and six
decades now this is all complicated by
the fact that according to the
conspiracy theorists the plot actually
wasn't well executed at all according to
them NASA did a shoddy job of pulling it
Off made a number of extremely obvious
mistakes mistakes that that were so
boneheaded that a bunch of people on
Twitter can easily spot them just by a
cursory glance at the photos so this was
a this was a a brilliant scheme but
pulled off by the most powerful entities
in human history that anyone on Twitter
could look at the photo for 5 seconds
ago but that was fake yep totally fake
now we'll get to those alleged mistakes
in a moment but you see the problem here
I hope in order for this Theory to work
the conspiracy would need to be the most
brilliant and well-coordinated and
devious hoax of all time and also the
dumbest and clumsiest and most obvious
it would need to be both of those things
simultaneously which it can't be and all
of this means that before we even look
at the supposed evidence we already have
a fake moon landing that is far more
complicated and difficult and
implausible than actually just landing
on the moon
we have an alternative theory that is by
far and way more convoluted and
farfetched than the official narrative
that it seeks to
debunk so Akim with his razor is is
spinning in his grave right now so what
is the evidence that can overcome this
enormous logical deficit what proof is
there that the moon landing was fake
well let's take a look at the three big
pieces of evidence that the deniers
offer and that has have been all over my
mentions on Twitter all weekend long so
first moonlanding deniers point to what
they consider to be anomalies in the
photographs taken on the moon and they
point out how uh you can't see any stars
in the sky right and you should be able
to because they were in space uh they
say that the Shadows are coming in at
weird angles rather than straight and
parallel as they should be if all the
Shadows are cast by a single light
source which would be the sun uh they
point to the picture of the American
flag appearing to wave as it stands
planted in the lunar surface they say
that this makes no sense because there
wouldn't have been any wind on the moon
to cause the flag to wave and and
finally they say that footage of the
lunar module taking off from the moon's
surface is clearly fake because there
wouldn't have been any cameraman Left
Behind to take the footage now of course
all of these points are very easily
explained the flag was not waving there
was a horizontal bar at the top of the
flag so there's the flag pole and then a
horizontal bar with the flag unfurling
underneath it and you can see this in
the picture if you look at it uh the
Stars aren't visible in the sky because
they landed during the lunar daytime and
the moon does have day and night time
you might not have known that they it
does and that's when the Sun's light
reflects brightly off the surface making
it so that you can't see the stars in
the in in the photo and as for the
Shadows there is absolutely absolutely
nothing strange about the fact that they
come in at different angles go outside
on a sunny day and take a picture and
you will see exactly the same phenomena
the uneven surface the angle of the lens
the perspective from where you take the
picture all will cause the Shadows to
appear that way again anyone could go
outside right at this very moment and
confirm this point yourself and uh how
did they get the footage of the lunar
module taking off well that footage is
from Apollo 17 not Apollo 11 uh they
left behind a camera that was controlled
remotely from Earth and the reason why
we didn't get that footage until Apollo
17 is because they tried it on two or
three other Moon missions and it didn't
work because it's sort of difficult to
pull off a remote controlled selfie on
the moon these are the easy Common Sense
accurate explanations for what you see
in the photographs and these
explanations make significantly more
sense than the alternative Theory okay
if if they were going to go through all
this trouble to to fake the
pictures why would they neglect to add
stars to the sky like wouldn't that be
the first thing you do if you were
faking a picture of outer
space why would they pretend the moon
has wind like the moonlanding deniers
are the ones who bring up these supposed
anomalies in the photos except that
their Theory makes less sense of the
anomalies than the story they're trying
to refute because the anomalies are not
anomalies they are very easily explained
and there's nothing mysterious or
strange about them Grand Canyon
University is an affordable private
Christian University based in Phoenix
Arizona they're dedicated to making
education fit into your busy schedule
which is why they offer 270 of their
academic programs online from
scholarships to academic support GCU
graduation team provides you with the
personal support you need to obtain your
goals gcu's online programs offer you
freedom to earn your degree on your own
time from wherever you are GCU is praise
for its culture of community giving an
impact the integrate the free market
system and a welcoming Christian
worldview into all of their academic
programs achieve your goals with a
personalized plan and a supportive team
behind you find your purpose at Grand
Canyon University private Christian
affordable visit gcu.edu that's gcu.edu
the second bit of evidence presented by
moonlanding deniers is the existence of
something called the Van Allen belt
which is a Zone surrounding the planet
inside the Earth's magnetic field field
that contains high levels of radiation
and the deniers say that astronauts
would be killed if they tried to pass
through it now this certainly would be a
devastating point if it was true but it
isn't the Van Allen belt does exist
there is radiation but the spacecraft
passes through it very quickly it's
going very fast and that minimizes the
radiation exposure and ultimately the
amount of radiation they're exposed to
isn't much more than a couple of chest
x-rays uh so it's you know you you can
be exposed to radiation without being
killed uh on the spot it's just if the
radiation is is uh mitigated and
minimized third and perhaps most
commonly cited piece of evidence to
support moonlanding denialism is that we
haven't gone back um as many people have
argued to me over the weekend if we
really landed on the moon then why
haven't we ever gone back well the first
answer is that we did we went back five
additional times so if you deny that
we've landed on the moon you are
actually claiming six Moon hoaxes you
were saying that this whole vast
conspiracy was spun up and planned and
executed six times in a row so so why
didn't we keep going to the Moon in
reality well how many times do you think
we should have gone I mean would you
find the story more credible if we went
10 times 20 times If you deny the first
six times will you suddenly believe it
if we go another six times like it it's
completely arbitrary well we only went
six times how many times should we have
gone U I don't
know
17 the real reason we stopped going to
the Moon is that it's expensive and it's
complicated and it's dangerous now it's
not as complicated as pulling off a
moonlanding hoax six times but it's
still it's it's it's complicated uh
people died to get the Apollo program
off the ground space travel is fraught
with risk and as a country we have lost
the will to endure the cost and take the
risk it's true that you know if you were
alive in 1970 you probably would have
assume that by the year 2024 we'd be
landing humans on the moons of Jupiter
right by now but it just watch any
scientific any science fiction film from
the 60s and70s to get an idea of where
people thought we'd be by the
2000s we didn't get there why well
because we lost interest and we slipped
into decadence and boredom and now to
top it all off IQ scores are declining
and people are generally becoming less
competent and less skilled in 1970 we
were sending Rockets to the Moon that's
true do you know what else we were doing
we were flying commercial supersonic
passenger jets that could make it from
New York to London in 3 hours and if you
were on one of those Jets 50 years ago
you would have assumed that by 2024 we'd
have the technology to go from New York
to London in three minutes right instead
we went the other way the fastest
passenger jet today that's operational
we'll get you there in about seven hours
okay our technology seems to have
regressed is that proof that the Concord
never existed does that mean that suic
air travel was a hoax no it just means
that the suponic air travel was again
expensive and difficult and cumbersome
and it came with extra risk risks one
crash of a Concord Jet uh which
eventually happened was all it took and
the whole supersonic air travel industry
was thrown on the scrap pile and that is
where it has stayed up until now we did
not build off of it uh we didn't
continue in that direction we just went
backwards it's a sad story it's a story
of societal paralysis and Decay but it
is not evidence that one of the most
well-documented events in human history
never happened in fact there is no
evidence that the moon landing never
happened there is again zero evidence of
this elaborate cinematic hoax I said
that I was responding to their evidence
but what you may have noticed about
their evidence is that it is not
evidence what the denialists have is a
few easily debunked qualms with the
generally accepted narrative they have
absolutely no positive evidence for
their own narrative not one single piece
of evidence not one witness not one
whistleblower with direct knowledge of
the conspiracy not one photo or video of
this hoax being staged nothing thing
they found some holes in the moonlanding
story holes that are totally imaginary
it turns out and inside those holes they
have stuffed this whole story that they
invented out of thin air which is a
problem because the moonlanding hoax
theory is not just a denial of something
that didn't of something that happened
right I'm not asking that you prove a
negative I'm not asking you to prove we
never went to the moon no no the
moonlanding hoax is an assertion of an
entirely different event that they claim
did happen and so what I'm saying is
where is your evidence that any of that
happened you have no
evidence to indicate that this event
occurred none at all zero now the moon
landing on the other hand has Reams and
Reams and reams of evidence there are
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
photos and videos from the surface
interviews with the astronauts who went
there footage from other lunar probes
that have gone to the moon or orbited it
there's even a laser reflector that was
left on the surface you can bounce a
laser off of it today this is a real
experiment that could be conducted right
now today to confirm that the reflector
was left there now it'll take much more
sophisticated equipment than the average
person has laying around but many people
with the equipment have done the
experiment because it measures measures
the distance between the Earth and the
moon at any given time and have
confirmed this are they all in on it too
is has the conspiracy grown even larger
now now if all of this is not enough to
believe that we landed on the moon then
fine but that means you also have to
deny pretty much every historical event
that has ever occurred there is more
direct evidence of the moon landing than
there is of almost any event that
happened prior to the mid 20th century
we have more direct evidence of the
moonlanding than we do that George
Washington existed and yet if I claim
that George Washington's existence was a
hoax you would expect me to present
extremely compelling direct positive
evidence of the hoax and if I had none
at all you would laugh in my face and
deservedly so skepticism is healthy but
flatly denying a historical event in
favor of a pet theory that has
infinitely less evidence to support it
than the event you're denying is not
skepticism it is dogmatism which is the
opposite of skepticism and that's why
there is no evidence of the moonlanding
that will ever convince the deniers no
matter what you show them they can
explain it away with some totally ad hoc
arbitrary wave of the hand photos won't
convince them video won't convince them
firsthand testimony won't convince them
eyewitnesses won't convince them lasers
bouncing off of freaking reflectors
planted on the moon's surface won't
convince them nothing will they have
chosen to deny everything ahead of time
and in this case what's being denied is
one of the greatest achievements in
human history an achievement claimed by
Americans for America the history of the
West is constantly being Rewritten by
bored spoiled people so as to diminish
the accomplishments of our ancestors and
deny their many incredible contributions
to Mankind and in the
end this is all part of that agenda if
there's any conspiracy going on here
there it is and that is why the
moonlanding deniers are with a great
Vengeance
canceled hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there